[Musik]
die Nachrichten des Tages heute mit
niedrige Siri schönen guten Abend ihnen
allen Katjas bei mir bei dir später
unter anderem Fußball Champions League
unter anderem genau schönen guten Abend
dann blicken wir gemeinsam auf unsere
Themen
ein Tag des Feierns ein Tag der Sorge
dieser Tag der Deutschen Einheit steht
auch im Zeichen wachsender Zweifel an
Zusammenhalt und Demokratie
was sind
atosekundenlichtimpulse sie helfen das
Universum zu verstehen sagt Ferenz Kraus
vom Münchner Max-Planck-Institut und
bekommt dafür den Physik Nobelpreis
und Schluss mit lustig auf der Wiesen
das Oktoberfest endet heute mehr als 7
Millionen Menschen waren dabei
[Musik]
der 33 Tag der Deutschen Einheit er
findet in schwierigen Zeiten statt
geprägt von großen Unsicherheiten die
damit verbundenen Herausforderungen
waren dann auch Thema beim Festakt in
der Hamburger Elbphilharmonie zugleich
gab es eine gut besuchte Festmeile in
der Hansestadt Ralf Zimmermann von
Siefert fast zusammen
unverkennbar ein Bürgerfest mit
Hamburger Akzent 100 tausende waren
heute auf den Beinen in ausgelassener
Stimmung und dennoch mit nachdenklichen
Tönen zum Thema deutscher Einheit 33
Jahre nach der Wiedervereinigung die
Einheit feiern wir die tatsächlich noch
oder ist es schon so Gewohnheit geworden
ich finde es sehr wichtig immer wieder
daran zu erinnern warum wir diesen Tag
eigentlich feiern
mitgebracht um noch mal zu
unterstreichen ist auch so um
Brüderlichkeit heutzutage geht das
werden die Freiheit erinnern die wir
errungen haben na ja und letztendlich
auch dass es darum geht dass vielleicht
ein Stück weit gerechter zugeht und die
Menschen von der Politik mit ihren
Problemen ernst genommen werden die
Einheitsfeier gewissermaßen auch als
Denkanstoß für politisches Handeln in
unruhigen Zeiten
zum Festakt in der Elbphilharmonie war
die gesamte Staatsspitze gekommen in
seiner Festrede mahnte der Präsident des
Bundesverfassungsgerichts Demokratie
brauche das Mitwirken aller Appell an
die politisch Handelnden unser Staat
muss deshalb tradierte Handlungsmuster
selbstkritisch überprüfen und anpassen
er muss lernen seine Komplexität zu
begrenzen und auch zu reduzieren er muss
auf allen Ebenen besser schneller vor
allem lösungsorientierter werden gerade
in epochalen Zeiten wie heute so Harvard
weiter müsse der Staat den Menschen
etwas zutrauen und die Menschen ebenso
sich selbst auch der Hamburger
Bürgermeister als Gastgeber fand
nachdenkliche Worte nicht Populismus und
Polarisierung sondern gemeinsam und
Kooperation sind das Gebot der Stunde
dafür tragen wir alle Verantwortung jede
und jeder Einzelne sollte sich fragen ob
sie oder er dazu einen Beitrag leisten
kann
es ging aber auch fröhlich zu einer
Einheitsfeier eben mit hamburgischen
Akzent
moin moin moin moin
[Musik]
die Wiedervereinigung sie hat den Osten
demografisch stark verändert viele junge
Menschen zogs in den Westen gleichzeitig
gingen die Geburtenzahlen zurück laut
Statistischen Bundesamt könnte dort die
Zahl der Menschen im erwerbsaltern den
nächsten 20 Jahren um bis zu 16%
schrumpfen Grund sei vor allem die
geringe Zuwanderung aus dem Ausland
immerhin seit einigen Jahren ziehen mehr
Menschen von West nach Ostdeutschland
als umgekehrt Anja campinos stellt zwei
von ihnen vor
Johanna und Flores leben seit einer
Weile in Boltenhagen an der Ostsee
wohnen 200 Meter vom Meer entfernt das
Paar zog aus München her hatte genug von
der Großstadt das ist von West nach Ost
ging spielte für sie keine Rolle also
ich bin ja schon im vereinigten
Deutschland aufgewachsen und da denke
ich eigentlich gar nicht darüber nach
Flores rollsch stammt aus Hamburg für
Johanna stockdreher ist es eine Rückkehr
in ihrer Heimat für beide das Zauberwort
Homeoffice es machte den Umzug möglich
dadurch dass wir Glasfaser haben
funktioniert das ganz gut das war
tatsächlich ein Hauptkriterium bevor wir
hochgezogen sind dass das erstmal bei
der Wohnung sein musste damit man eben
vernünftig arbeiten kann
letztes Jahr zogen 1000 Menschen mehr
von West nach Ost als umgekehrt ein
stabiler Trend er macht Geburtenknick
und Abwanderung nach dem Mauerfall aber
nicht weg Mangel an Facharbeitern und
Servicekräften ist vor allem im Osten
die größte Wohlstand Bedrohung sagen
Unternehmensverbände ich glaube dass wir
ohne gezielte Zuwanderung ohne gezielte
Akquisitionen in Arbeitsplätze in
Arbeitskräfte auch hier vor Ort nicht
zurechtkommen werden es müsste klar sein
Zuwanderung sei Chance statt Problem so
der ostbeauftragte der Bundesregierung
und das ist ein Umkehr dessen was so
gelernt ist gelernt ist ja wir verlieren
Leute nein
wir haben jetzt Jobs offen wir brauchen
Leute mehr Leute wie Johanna und Flores
im Ostseebad Boltenhagen
am dritten Oktober da wird ja immer auch
der deutsch-deutsche Beziehungsstatus
hinterfragt und für eine Doku habe ich
die Perspektive erweitert und habe
sowohl ostdeutsche als auch zugewanderte
befragt die schon lange bei uns leben
und was man nicht sofort denken würde
beide Gruppen teilen ähnliche
Erfahrungen
es geht um harte Brüche in der Biografie
und auch um fehlende Anerkennung
Cornelia Hilsberg leitet heute das
weberei-museum in Braunsdorf bei
Chemnitz ihre Ausbildung und
Berufsträume platzen mit der Wände ich
war gerade fertig mit meiner Ausbildung
zum textilfacharbeiter mit Abitur und
mit einem Mal war die Ausbildung
hinfällig also ich stand noch drei
Jahren komplett vom Nichts und hat mir
gesagt ja wer bin ich was habe ich bis
jetzt gemacht millionenfacher Identität
und Jobverlust innerhalb kürzester Zeit
das machen sich im Westen vermutlich nur
wenige bewusst diese unglaubliche
Schnitte dieser Bruch den wir erlebt
haben und das ist eben nicht anerkannt
wurde dass das immer noch wirkt quasi
bei Null anfangen sich stärker beweisen
als die westdeutsche
Mehrheitsgesellschaft das kennen auch
zugewanderte und ihre Kinder
Konditorei die sie von ihrem Vater
übernommen hat und sie beklagt fehlende
Anerkennung
traurig finde ist dass man dann immer
sagt man ist die Ausnahme man ist die
Ausnahme aber es ist nicht mehr ja aber
es ist nicht mehr die Ausnahme es ist
die Mehrheit die zweite Generation die
hier lebt hat so viel geschaffen was
vielleicht viele Deutsche nicht
geschaffen haben Vielfalt und
ostdeutsche Identität dazu habe ich auch
das erste TV-Interview mit Angela Merkel
führen können nach ihrer Regierungszeit
und sie teilt auch persönliche
Geschichten mit uns zum Beispiel ihre
Eindrücke zum einheitssymbol viele Jahre
habe ich immer ein ganz bestimmtes
Gefühl gehabt wenn ich durch das
Brandenburger Tor gegangen bin also das
hat sich erst nach bestimmt 15 Jahren
normalisiert immer etwas Besonderes
ja die ganze Doku mit mir aus der Reihe
am Puls die gibt's gleich hier im ZDF
nach dieser Sendung der Titel wie viel
Einheit haben wir erreicht
ja am Tag der Deutschen Einheit da wird
auch der Tag der offenen Moschee
begangen rund 1000 Gottes Häuser haben
seit dem Morgen ihre Pforten für
interessierte Gäste geöffnet es gehe
darum friedliche islamische Werte zu
vermitteln so der Koordinationsrat der
Muslime den Aktionstag gibt es schon
seit 1997
die EU in Brüssel die braucht einen
neuen klimaschäft der Posten extrem
wichtig denn er muss das Kernprojekt der
EU den Green Deal umsetzen also die
Union bis 2050 klimaneutral umbauen er
war der bisherige klimakommissar Franz
Timmermanns und er kandidiert jetzt in
seiner Heimat Niederlande für die
Parlamentswahl und er soll der neue
werden wobke hugstra auch Niederländer
der 48-Jährige Christdemokrat hat unter
anderem für den Ölkonzern gearbeitet und
viele EU-Abgeordnete fragen sich kann so
einer klimaschaff werden dazu Krüger
bis vor zwei Stunden die Parlamentarier
und ihre Antwort lautet vorerst nein
bisher gibt es keine Chance für eine
zwei Drittel Mehrheit
wobbke hubtrahab genau darum gestern im
Umweltausschuss setzte 90% weniger
Treibhausgase als Zwischenziel für 2014
bis 2050 das wird dann ein steiler
Anstieg aber es gibt keine Alternative
wir können es schaffen zusammen
Vorgänger Timmermanns warfen
konservative vor er sei zu kompromisslos
beim green Deal sein Nachfolger sei
pragmatischer green Deal 2.0 heißt für
mich Fokussierung auf Wirtschaft und
Klimaneutralität und nicht jeden grünen
Wunsch erfüllen der diesen beiden Zielen
oft im Wege steht die Grünen sehen die
personale hugstrain einer Kette von
Rückschlägen das Gesetz zur
Renaturierung Stutzen die Konservativen
im Parlament das zur Energieeffizienz
Schwächen Staaten wie Deutschland gerade
wieder ab und auch das zur Luftqualität
hat Gegenwind extra kommt von den
Konservativen die im letzten Jahr hier
gegen jedes Klimaschutzgesetz gestimmt
haben das so jemand jetzt den
Klimaschutz federführend übernimmt da
mag da kann man erstmal berechtigte
Zweifel haben um sie auszuräumen soll
Hooks kann nun schriftlich antworten
geben es sieht trotzdem danach aus dass
er Brüssels Mann fürs Klima wird
jetzt zu einer richtungsweisenden
Entscheidung das armenische Parlament
hat mit großer Mehrheit für den Beitritt
des Landes zum Internationalen
Strafgerichtshof gestimmt Armenien wirft
seiner bisherigen Schutzmatte Russland
vor im Konflikt und Berg Karabach nicht
eingegriffen zu haben Mitgliedsländer
des Internationalen Strafgerichtshof
sind verpflichtet russlands Präsident
Putin zu verhaften sobald er ihr
Territorium betrifft
wir gehen nach Moskau zu Armin Körper
Armin Armenien wendet sich mit diesem
Schritt ja von Moskau ab wie reagiert
der Krimi jetzt
gremmelsprechert metriaskov hat diese
Entscheidung heute Nachmittag vor
Journalisten als unangemessen bezeichnet
eine Entscheidung die die diplomatischen
Beziehungen zwischen den Ländern
deutlich belastet man habe jetzt Fragen
an die armenische Regierung welche das
sind hat er uns leider nicht verraten
ich denke man kann davon ausgehen dass
mindestens eine Frage sich auf die
militärische Zusammenarbeit zwischen
Russland und Armenien bezieht Russland
kontrolliert die armenische Grenze zur
Türkei z.B und das Land betreibt auch
Militärstützpunkte in Armenien fest
steht die Regierung von Nicole
passhinian hat sich von Russland ein
Stück weiter abgewandt und sich damit
auf einen weiteren Stufe der Eskalation
begeben aus Sicht Moskau dass der Kreml
sowas nicht gerne sieht ist hinreichend
bekannt bei der Frage was daraus jetzt
folgt beginnt man sich in dem Bereich
der Spekulation ich denke Pasching Jan
sitzt auf einem sehr wackeligen Stuhl
und es ist Durchfall durchaus denkbar
dass die Pro russische Opposition im
Land Zukunft und plötzliche und
unerwartete Unterstützung erfährt eine
interessante Bemerkung noch zum Schluss
mir viel auf dass pierzkov diese
Parlamentsentscheidung aus Armenien als
eine Idee und nicht mehr als das
bezeichnet hat das lässt natürlich auch
tief blicken wie man im Kreml auf
demokratische Prozesse in souveränen
Nachbarländern blickt live aus Moskau
Armin Körper vielen Dank
in die Türkei nach dem Bombenanschlag in
Ankara am Wochenende geht die Polizei
hart gegen vermeintlich militante Kurden
vor laut Innenministerium wurden
hunderte Verdächtige mit möglichen
Verbindungen zur verbotenen
Arbeiterpartei PKK festgenommen am
Sonntag hatten zwei Angreifer im
Regierungsviertel in Ankara eine Bombe
gezündet die PKK hat sich zu dem
Anschlag bekannt
den Physik Nobelpreis bekommt in diesem
Jahr auch ein Forscher in München
Ferienhaus erteilt sich die Auszeichnung
mit der in Schweden lebenden analya und
dem Franzosen Pierre augustini sie sind
sozusagen Paparazzi auf der Jagd nach
einem winzigen Teilchen dem Elektron
dazu verwenden Sie unfassbar kurze
Lichtblitze über Schnappschüsse in der
Welt der Atome berichtet jetzt Lena
sünderbruch
herrens Kraus macht weiter was er immer
macht forschen und erklären am
Max-Planck-Institut für Quantenoptik in
Garching auch an einem Tag wie diesem
als frischgebackener Nobelpreisträger
ich versuche durchzuatmen dazu ist es
bisher nicht gekommen also ich bin immer
noch überwältigt ich habe damit in
keinster Weise gerechnet das
Nobelkomitee hat ihn zusammen mit der
Französin an Julie und ihrem Landsmann
Pierre Agostini ausgezeichnet für eine
Art
hochgeschwindigkeitsfotografie ein
Kolibri kann 80 Mal pro Sekunde mit den
Flügeln schlagen schon das mit unseren
Sinnen unmöglich exakt zu erfassen mit
technischen Hilfsmitteln schon in ihren
Experimenten haben Lilly kraus und
augustini Laserimpulse erzeugt die sogar
Vorgänge in Atomen und Molekülen
einfangen sie machen Schnappschüsse von
extrem schnellen Bewegungen der
Elektronen in attosekunden ein
Milliardstel einer milliardstel Sekunde
die Erkenntnisse der drei
Nobelpreisträger eröffnen neue
Perspektiven zum Beispiel in der Medizin
da geht es darum ob Krankheiten unsere
molekulare
Zusammensetzung unseres Blutes verändern
und dass man diese Moleküle praktisch
direkt feststellen kann er arbeitet wenn
ich das recht erinnere an dem Projekt wo
zum Beispiel Krebspatienten
identifiziert werden konnten durch die
durch die Wechselwirkung von von Licht
mit Materie hat also praktisch eine ganz
frühe frü-erkennung wird es dann
mitgeben und nicht nur das die Arbeit
der Nobelpreisträger könnte in Zukunft
auch etwa leistungsfähigere Computer
möglich machen
gut zwei Wochen lang wurde in XXL Manier
gefeiert beim Oktoberfest mit den drei
konstanten Brauchtum Brezen und
Bierkultur mit Betonung auf Bier heute
aber ist Schluss mit der geselligen
Gaudi die Bilanz positiv es blieb
friedlich und es kamen so viele Besucher
wie nie Svenja Berger auf
auf der Festwiese in den Biergärten und
Zelten der Münchner Theresienwiese gab
es 18 Tage Volksfest pur 7,2 Millionen
Besucher kamen dieses Jahr allzeitrekord
auch am letzten oktoberfesttag ist ganz
schön was los
gestern hier vorgestern hier und ich
glaube auch vorgestern hier und ähm ja
letztes Mal muss man einfach hier sein
um den Ausgang einfach mit mitnehmen
oder das ist doch eine gute Idee
keinen Rekord gab es beim
gerstensaftkonsum kaum verwunderlich bei
teilweise fast 15 € pro Mars stattdessen
wurden deutlich mehr alkoholfreie
Getränke verkauft Veranstalter und
Sicherheitskräfte blicken insgesamt
zufrieden auf die diesjährige gewesen
locker und fröhlich sei alles gewesen
weitgehend entspannten wieseneinsatz
zurückblicken können enormen Rückgang im
Bereich der Taschen gibt Stelle also wir
haben 40% weniger Fälle hier die
angezeigt wurden daneben weniger Unfälle
weniger betrunkene Minderjährige eine
sehr positive Bilanz dazu beschert das
wahrlich königlich bayerische Wetter
Schaustellern und wirken Einsatz
daran dass dieses festsitzen in den
Zelten das letztes Jahr natürlich
wärmebedingt oder besser gesagt Kälte
bedingt aber nicht passiert ist das
freut mich einfach weiter mit jeder von
der Wiesen auch was verdient hat noch
einmal werden heute Abend in den Zelten
die Krüge gehoben dann aber heißt
austrunken ist und bis zum nächsten Jahr
oh mein Gott so jetzt zum Fußball Katja
zweiter Spieltag steht an in der
Champions League Gruppenphase ja seit
ein paar Minuten spielt Union Berlin
gegen Sporting Braga aus Portugal und
später dann sind die Bayern in Dänemark
beim FC Kopenhagen zu Gast die Münchner
sind klare Favoriten und Gesprächsthemen
gibt's wie immer genug
die Bayern und ihr Trainer vom Champions
League Gruppenspiel in Kopenhagen mit
dabei top Stürmer Harry Kane und der
derzeit überragende Leroy sané
Gesprächsthema Nummer 1 aber die
umstrittene mögliche Verpflichtung von
Ex-Spieler Jérôme Boateng den wegen des
Vorwurfs häusliche Gewalt eine Strafe
droht das Geld ja trotzdem die
Unschuldsvermutung wenn Verfahren
ausgesetzt ist weil das auch so ist
haben wir trotzdem als Fußballclub auch
das Recht Fußball Entscheidungen zu
treffen das sportliche bei den Bayern
derzeit im Hintergrund Aufreger Thema
Nummer zwei Max Eberl soll kommen würde
dem neuen Sport Direktor vor die Nase
gesetzt ich bin mir extrem wohl und
alles andere ist nicht in meine
Entscheidung der will ja gar nicht herum
drucksen das ist die Wahrheit zuletzt
gegen Leipzig was sportlich durchwachsen
jetzt soll es erstmal auf dem Rasen
durchgängig besser klappen versuchen
besser Plan
zu entwickeln der eventuell auch besser
passt und versuchen dann den Plan
natürlich auch
mit mehr Leben zu füllen ausgeschlafen
und als Team zum Auswärtssieg dann
hätten sie auch wieder Grund zu
ausgelassener Freude
dicke Tränen dagegen bei den deutschen
Turnerinnen sie haben die
Olympia-Qualifikation verpasst die
Winzigkeit von 0,169 Punkten fehlten bei
der WM in Antwerpen für das Team Finale
und damit für das ersehnte Ticket nach
Paris aber immerhin konnte sich Pauline
Schäfer Betz als beste deutsche
Mehrkämpferin einen Einzel Startplatz
für Olympia sichern nichts wird mit dem
Titel für Tennisprofi Alexander Zverev
beim ATP Turnier in Peking im Halbfinale
verloren gegen den Russen Daniel mit 4
zu 6 und 3 6 es war von Beginn an ein
hochklassiges Match mit den ersten Break
Chancen für den leicht erkälteten
deutschen aber am Ende war medwede
frischer ass zum Match gewinnen im
Finale später nun gegen den Italiener
Jannik Sina und zwar der steht gleich
weiter in Shanghai bei Masters danke dir
Katja
so und zum Schluss haben wir noch ein
ganz besonderen Rekord das ist Dorothy
Hoffner fantastische 104 Jahre alt sie
Stürze sich per Fallschirm 4000 Meter in
die Tiefe eine wundervolle Erfahrung
sagte die US-Amerikanerin zurück auf dem
Boden und eine Erfahrung die ihr einen
Eintrag ins Guinness Buch der Rekorde
einbringen wird denn dorisi ist ein Jahr
älter als die bisherige Rekordhalterin
nicht schlecht sehr gut so nach einem
Teil stürmischen Abend beruhigt sich das
Wetter morgen wieder Einzelheiten gleich
von Christa Orben um 21:45 Uhr sehen Sie
das heute journal mit Marietta Slomka
für Sie noch einen schönen
feiertagsabend und bis morgen wenn Sie
mögen
[Musik]
guten Abend ja diese kaltfrontier
vertreibt gerade unsere spätsommerliche
Luft in der es heute noch einmal fast 30
Grad gab vor allem aber bringt uns diese
Kaltfront ordentlich Wind mit und Regen
der gerade den Südosten des Landes
erreicht darin eingelagert sind Gewitter
und Vorsicht in diesem Gewittern und an
der Front selbst sind schwere Sturmböen
möglich ab Mitternacht zieht das ganze
dann aber schnell raus und dann gibt es
nur im Norden noch kurze Schauer und
Gewitter am Morgen ist es im Norden
windig und wechselhaft in der Mitte ist
es aber trocken und Sonne und Wolken
wechseln sich ab südlich des meines
scheint nach Nebel Auflösung häufig die
Sonne die Temperaturen es wird
herbstlich frisch heute Nacht bei 6 bis
11 Grad an der See gibt es 13 Grad
morgen erreichen wir dann Werte zwischen
16 Grad an den Alpen und 21 Grad am
Oberrhein und befinden uns schon eher im
Normalbereich für Oktober zum nächsten
Wochenende allerdings da steigen die
Temperaturen dann noch mal und es gibt
ein Sommer Internet so im Oktober
tschüss